we have a voicemail number which is two
one nine two david p here's a question
that many in the audience have been
asking while others in the audience
reject the framing let's take a listen
to the question hey David
Yvonne from Corona California just
wondering why do progressive love losing
so much seriously I'm getting sick of it
I mean this whole a ococ business and
you know people getting mad about you
know her actually trying to be a
politician and you know people saying
they won't fall for Biden yeah I'm sick
of it and I'm certainly think
progressives just like losing anyways
thanks so yeah I mean this is a fair
question not everybody agrees with the
framing the the it's not clear not not
all progressives like losing I think
there's a couple things going on there
are progressives who have taken the
position that short-term losses serve
some bigger purpose that will be a
future win of some kind that's a
position that is not an irrational
position I just don't think it's
practical and I don't think it actually
works but you can rationally come to the
conclusion that you're willing to
tolerate short term and even medium-term
losses for some sort of longer-term win
there are also people who genuinely
don't see what you and I might see as a
loss as a loss right like there's
disagreement there the aoc thing is a
perfect example
ICAO sees move to pragmatism as a
positive thing that suggests she has
better political instincts than I maybe
previously thought I got crushed for
that position yesterday on the program
and a ton of people wrote to me saying
this is simply not a win in other words
it's not incremental ISM versus
revolution it's simply disagreeing that
this is going to lead to any kind of
wind so I don't believe progressives
love losing however there is a fraction
of progressives who prefer to be in the
underdog victim martyr always trying to
claw from behind position and that is
very
motivating to a lot of people it's a
good business strategy I know that
there's a lot of you know sort of
activism outfits that essentially are
constantly fundraising on the basis of
this come-from-behind martyr victim
position so I think that there's a
little bit of everything there's there's
a sort of all of the above
I don't believe most progressives like
losing they just have a disagreement
about what it we what it means to win or
lose at a fundamental level remember
that we will be doing a big membership
bomb on April 9th huge membership
discount code will be going out by email
be notified by getting on our mailing
list at david pakman.com on the bonus
show today producer pats triumphant
return we will hear about the ceiling
caving in we will hear about it raining
inside Pat's apartment Pat will be back
today and we will have much more to
discuss get instant access to the bonus
show by becoming a member at join
pakman.com or a patron at patreon.com
slash david pakman show